president Trump will unveil his national
security strategy in a speech today and
he will single out China and Russia
threat to American interest
the president spoke again yesterday with
Russian President Vladimir Putin he
thanked mr. Trump for sharing
information from the CIA that allowed
Russia to prevent a terror attack in st.
Petersburg Russia made arrests and found
weapons and bomb materials Margaret
Brennan is at the White House Margaret
good morning good morning well the two
presidents spoke yesterday for the
second time in four days and in a rare
optimistic statement Vladimir Putin
thanked mr. Trump and the CIA for
providing that information that helped
to thwart that potential terrorist
attack on Russian soil the White House
is calling it an example quote of the
positive things that can occur when our
countries work together notably for mr.
Trump he did praised the CIA in contrast
to his own past criticism of that agency
in this case he thanked quote the entire
intelligence community on a job well
done but this afternoon when mr. Trump
unveils his national security strategy
the president will call out Russia as
well as China as threats he'll refer to
them as quote revisionist powers
attempting to erode American security
and prosperity now that puts those two
challengers on par with Iran North Korea
and terrorist groups as undermining the
United States so it is clear Anthony
from the national security council's
point of view here that they see mr.
Putin as an adversary despite the
administration attempts to broker
friendlier relations Margaret Brennan
thanks Margaret